to turn off more here again today I'm
not going to be doing a knockout
necessarily as I'm gonna be competing in
this protest League qualifier for the
Seattle sluggers so the format's
probably gonna be a little bit different
today but uh still it should be on
should be quite interesting to say the
least so looking forward to it it's I
think supposed start in about five
minutes or thereabout so you guys have
any questions or things like that go
ahead and type in the chat and and yeah
so I'll let you guys know if you have
questions and so forth just just let me
know so alright everyone so as I was
saying about five more minutes I see
that I have fun live now so I see some
people a chat room um again it's about
five minutes till it starts I think it's
supposed to be 15 15 rounds of blitz
three minutes with two second increment
so so yeah so so basically just waiting
till the amount starts in five minutes I
think it's just as straight Swiss so
it's basically like an extended title
Tuesday if I understand correctly so um
so so yeah so so let's let's again if
you guys have any questions just asking
some questions since it's about five
minutes so um I don't see any questions
yup but again if you do just a go ahead
and ask
so I see a Toshio lama asked funny
question he says okay it's it's miss
written me basically saying how many bon
thoughts do you plan on playing oh it's
15 rounds I don't think I'll be playing
any because this is a team event
so if this was some kind of you know
normal what normal sort of um that that
um that would be different anyway I see
there was a cheer bike kitty kitty
hisses a little a little bit new to this
whole twitch partner thing but I just
got a set up today so we'll see how it
works out oh and in case you guys are
saying the microphones a little bit loud
that might be because I have headphones
in right now I was planning on listening
to music when uh when I went to play so
I might I might take out the headphones
so I thought generally if I have a
microphone on and I'm playing at this or
not playing sorry but if I have
microphone and I have headphones and
generally I tend to speak quite a bit
louder than normal so that's that's
probably what it is more than anything
so so so that might be why the sound is
very slightly uh loud we just switch
back I'm sure yeah it looks like I'm
yeah I'm in it so it starts in three
minutes so uh I'll let you guys looking
forward to it as I said before it's -
it's 15 uh it's 15 rounds I think it's
just straight blitz three minutes two
second increment but I think because
there's a team event it's like all for
your team members so like even if I go
like 15 and oh for example it's the rest
of my team does badly I think that that
I would uh that that wouldn't be enough
for us to qualify if I understand
correctly I think it's based on the
number of points you have overall but
we'll see it anyway it so it's gonna be
interesting so also generally when i've
streamed it hasn't been during important
events this will be a little bit of a
new thing for me I mean I considered
streaming once during a title Tuesday of
up but then I
not to Toshio a llama says who's in your
team playing for these Seattle sluggers
I suspect them to mean webpage of chess
comm there should be an actual list of
the of the teams and the people who are
competing today but I'm not certain
about that at any rate so I'm so so so
we'll see and I see swag master ofc
writes hello Nico first time tuning
inter stream that's great it's good to
see that there are new people coming in
to watch a stream so hopefully uh
hopefully I perform well today I think
my last remote want perfect I did
something like I think I won 35 35 out
of 35 games or something I suspect today
it won't be quite like that but what
we'll see at any rate so okay looks like
we're one minute away so yeah so so for
now I'm actually all speak but I'm gonna
put in some I am I'm gonna put on some
headphones and play some play some music
at the same time um so uh obviously a
comment as well because multitasking is
totally my thing these days so yeah
alright
probably not actually this Roy's like I
probably shouldn't play music slide
please gone YouTube that's gonna slow
down the string yeah I'm probably making
me wagon and there's nothing like what
I'm playing today that actually being
really really disastrous so I'm just
gonna focus I guess on the event um
prime shoe says Metallica I mean not
exactly if I if I'm playing something
well totally serious and actually looks
like the game has begun so this is the
first first game 15 I'm playing as
hashtags FM from Greenland I don't know
if that's actually where he's from but
I'm gonna start with playing b3 bitter B
to play a bird see what he wants to do
now anyone who's watched a stream before
is really familiar with this position
I've had it many many times I think most
recently I played this is like probably
like 15 to 20 times against this ask
them from from France when I was just
being him in late game after game his
playing was very similar set up so
blacks given up to two bishops i have
the two bishops on the two diagonals
here and at the same that I do have
these double a pawns as well so he's
probably gonna play Bishop f6 try to
exchange I'm not gonna let him know I
can play d4 I'm gonna play c3 just not
not to make the structure to to set
basically leaving ideas of d4 c4 so
available as opposed to simply I'm
simply playing simply having to you know
I play d4 you play c5 in the structure
specs but here it's not and here he
plays EE 5 which I'm not a big fan of is
now the one thing one chunk he had it
the evening the two bishop pair but I
had these double a pawns but by 25
now he's now I've eliminated the double
and eliminated double F pawns and I'm
gonna play d4 now see if she plays 93
Bishop e3 so probably now ago 97 but
once he was 97 he can't really play c5
because then I'm holding this d5 pawn so
we'll probably go to g6 our d7 one of
those two squares it goes at g6 now I'm
gonna play age for me to play h5 kick
the night away from this g6 square so he
plays each six slightly strange but now
I'm gonna play h5
87 I'm gonna play Bishop e3 pin the
knight to the rook rook e8 now I think
I'm gonna play Bishop h3 so that his
knight still is no square so now I've
got Noah five square for his Knight I
control this diagonal and I'm basically
asking him how he plans to finish his
development so all those pieces are a
little bit uncomfortable so he goes
ninety seven I'm gonna play rook e1
probably hope goodnight f8 here but not
sure so sure enough he does now I'm
gonna play Knight up one try to redirect
my knight maybe each to g4 III g4
some mix of these moves Oh w-k-n-o says
what a sound quality um is there
something wrong with the UH with my
microphone and way he plays Queen a5
I can go B for B to C is he attacking
both the bishop and the pawn I'm gonna
go to be for just keep keeping
depression on this diagonal of a 93
so sound is weird okay that's not good
done
sound it's weird maybe not using the
right microphone or something anyway I
can turn the sound well let me see is it
better now maybe is it sound better
are you sure the sound down a bit I
don't know if this is better or not for
you guys but I don't know is it is it
okay now or not I mean I turn the volume
down a little bit so I don't know is
there static maybe it's maybe maybe it's
a fan I don't know let me see if it's
better now without the fan obviously now
I'm gonna get really hot but um not sure
anyway we repeat the aeroplane he4
attack the fish 106 goes 97 to protect
it now I could take I think I'm just
gonna play Queen b3 develop my queen dr.
Brooks here on a1 and a1 also maybe now
he knows Bishop to g5 I have four ideas
later since the Queen protects g3
potentially well this night see it was a
strange move maybe once exchange maybe
dozen I'm not really sure or actually
care probably want schoolish east of it
that's actually probably want to do so
now I could take I can probably play f4
maybe seems a little bit weird I'd
really like this Bishop to be here on d3
not Age 3 here so maybe in fact lonely
night g4 was slightly wrong
couldn't play cleanup three I mean he
really wants to go bish b7 I think so
how to prevent that
the first flash player key to probably
can just take and play this be seven but
I don't see anything better so I'm gonna
play work III so again um is is it is it
better or you still the same problems
here with the UH with the sound okay so
turning off the fan did not improve it
okay that's that's not good um it takes
I think what the Queen try to control
this e-file there should be seven as I
as I was expecting I could take I could
also put like this e5 I mean she's
trying to be very very salt I'm gonna
play something slightly unusual here I
think maybe Bishop c5 or not to be or
not to be not to be to be or not to be
let's say okay now I could play ninety
five here I could take promise I'm gonna
be losing the bishop pair now so I've
kind of miss play this very slightly I'm
gonna play Bishop c5 I'm gonna try to
make this a little bit a little bit
unusual here oh well maybe he'll take
maybe he won't I'm not sure what we'll
say so he plays b6 but now I created a
weakness what is positive I never got
this Knight to e5 this pawn on c6 is
very weak
I'm gonna go 95 this still should be
very slightly better for me um so let's
see um h e5 now I think I can take on
can I take oh wait no it's check on h3
it's just Chuck okay so I'll go Bishop
g4 protect the bishop maybe play off for
this Queen e8 on play Rocky one is 96
I could retreat the night I could play
f3 also but then he's got f5 so I'm just
gonna play prophylactic kingi to put my
King on a better square maybe keep ideas
out for f3 everything open now plays f6
which i think is
that I can I see six takes takes and the
thing is my fonts all in f2 so I always
have a 3 so ephors never actually gonna
stop anything if you put tonight here
let's see 5 now rookie 7 looks
interesting I could take on c5 I can
also play 97 many different
possibilities um I'm gonna probably put
the simplest he's low on time and I know
for sure I'm winning a pawn here so it
seems like the safest way to go rather
than going for complications or maybe
black is some chances and also this is
this is there is a 2 second increment so
it's gonna be a lot harder to flag
people than it would be if it was a
straight through yo so night 11 night of
four keep both these six g6 lives go
fish b6 in the night night and the King
age 7 I'm gonna night u6 take away the
e5 square from his night was rook e8 I
could take the night I mean probably
taking is good enough but I don't really
want or if I play out for a lot of 98 so
I'm just okay he wants to move his night
that's that's for sure so the question
oh wait actually I'm pretty long time to
here so I gotta move fast also so Chuck
take 86 I'll play c4 I soon be for a4
I'm just gonna try to try to use these
outside pass pawns also he's got
weaknesses here because of this
structure so I've also got Knight f5 as
well
the pond is 5 I mean even if he got c3
he should be much slower than me like d6
d7
I wasn't expecting him to play quiet
like this although I've kind of made
this very messy wait can't I Queen age 7
or something I've really must played
this um do I want to take I kind of have
to you don't have a choice
it was 97 in 96 kind of tried a boxes
night
now King Keaney 705 takes takes as a
draw so go back to f4 okay let's see so
now actually again I have plenty of time
still in 295 okay how to win this let's
see six maybe
I've got Chuck and Knight f6 yeah now i
now I've got Chuck Knight takes f6 and
now this is just winning well why didn't
it plane I never should put this night
on g4 here that was really pretty stupid
b5 and g4 yeah this this has to be
winning though
could have played 95 also but see me on
this is still tricky somehow it's still
not easy 96 95 97 King C sucks and yeah
I know I'm just gonna win cuz the pawns
gonna be too advanced you sips I D I
know it's just over so you can't stop
the pond gonna go g5 and yeah okay
that's the end of the game so that's one
down so um
so quality of the stream is fine it's
it's on um it's fine on your end okay so
I see you guys here saying it's good I
think Thanks
Kirkwood just subscribe so think think
scribing to my stream okay yeah if
everything's good let me know if not let
me know as well now my own game
technique there was pretty pretty
terrible I'm not gonna I'm not gonna lie
about that I was just terrible
but when you say that say say move the
microphone I mean closer or further away
I'm a little confused I'll move it a
little further away now I don't know
maybe it's better now or maybe it's not
um I don't know mm-hm it could just be I
mean there's some slight sound coming
from my computer as well so I'll just
I'll move the microphone further away
so let's this is about as far as I'm
gonna move it so okay hopefully this is
better I don't know I don't I don't know
if this is good or not I mean keep
moving it I don't think I need a better
microphone I'm using the Sampson
professional what I'm not using uh not
using just a random microphone so I'm
not sure I mean I can keep playing
around with it see what happens and so
forth but so so anyway yeah alright so
okay so that's that's one down um so
okay so that's what so kitty kitty hits
hit says can you play Eric on the this
this time I'm playing right now is a
tournament event but I can definitely
try to play them afterwards if he's if
he's around I'm not sure but we'll see
so
anyway so that's what that's one down
now I'm here from the team manager that
I guess we scored three out of four in
the first round so pretty good pretty
good start for my team but you got 15
rounds is a lot of rounds so so we'll
say so so anyway I see Eric is is hiding
in the chat here instead of being on the
on-site playing right now I think but
I'm sure I'll get the chance to plan
after after the event that is assuming I
mean I don't know this is 15 rounds of
three two so this this event might take
like four hours like this I'm not
expecting this to be a short event so I
mean yeah I see some other questions
layin are zero zero wrote what do you
what what did you think of that Corey a
can of a match um I I didn't watch much
I watch all of about 10 minutes actually
I mean I I basically turn in very
briefly for the I like tuned in for five
five or 10 minutes very briefly during
streaming a portion I saw that Surya was
just he had 192 in the five minutes so I
didn't really see the point to hang
around and watching because I figured he
was he was gonna win the match easily
and I think he did I don't actually know
the end result but I'm presuming he won
so so yeah anyway again I see kitty
kisses says can you can you please flag
Erik what's it say can you please fly
Erik with the bong powder after he king
f2 when you play him oh did I have a
game started to it oh whoops
d4 okay whoops okay I better start
moving
I didn't notice the game started sorry
about that everybody anyway we need to
all play d5 now I've had this position
many many times as most of you know as
well
I had a three-night of six probably 597
or an IP d2 c 5b 597 c3 Queen c8 I'm
gonna go fish basics next move try to
exchange everything on the light squares
castles fish base sex probably takes
takes likely we're gonna exchange all
all the pieces here on the on the light
squares see force possible in knight c6
so plays Knight g5 but here I think in
this position is slightly dubious I
gotta take I'm gonna play Bishop to d7 I
mean I could have played Bishop e7 right
away as well actually maybe that was
it's just a transposition I please f4
that's an interesting no that's not what
I was expecting so I'm gonna take try to
open it up right away I could play each
six maybe he's gonna take on e6 maybe
not queen h6 makes sense I'm just gonna
play Queen eight six try to exchange
she's obviously gonna move the Queen
away to like g3 knight c6 tacked upon
here on d4 so he goes Knight f3 now I
could play each six I suppose but I'm
just gonna play cheese six be solid and
because I always have h6 looming here if
I need it so if I need it that is so you
please push III not what to do - I want
to take on g5 do I want to retreat my
bishop that's a little bit extravagant
but I'm gonna do that I want to play
push buffet me age three okay so he
really wants to take I'm gonna go 98
protect everything here
please g4 wow he's very aggressive now
that plane each six he wants to go f5 I
assume a5 Bishop g7 f6 each six f5 takes
takes Queen d3 interesting I think I'll
play aged six I'm gonna see what he does
he's gonna go f5 here I'm gonna take a
Kwan's or do I actually do I want to
play Queen d3 first that's also an
option to is so Queen d3 I think I'm
gonna play Queen d3 first because now
I'm now I'm attacking this pawn with
both my pawns and my queen so okay you
wanna nominate 8 when he takes I'm just
gonna play Queen out 5 or work g8 maybe
Ruchi it actually looks pretty
convincing isn't this just a free piece
egg stakes I don't see it I don't see it
so I'm just gonna play work g8 when I
take I don't see it I think I'm just
winning here I think I'm just up a piece
and completely winning but again in
these sorts of positions you have to be
very careful so it could be an instant
tactic so he takes now I can I can just
take the bishop as I want I don't have
to but it feels like the most practical
thing to do just to get rid of any of
the pressure and maybe I I have two
pieces for the rook and I'm only down
one pawn here and his structures not not
perfect I mean I can't undermine this d4
pawn very easily here let's rock c1 I
can take I can play like knight c6 or
rook c4 I think I'll just play work c4
force them to exchange
I probably I didn't take the bish 1g5 I
coulda just played queen takes out five
and it was just game over I mean this
was probably pretty unnecessary to allow
but this still should be winning Wow b3
okay so clearly he thinks he's just
completely busted so I mean otherwise
there's no reason to try and just tease
desperate to keep Brooks on the board
and try to get rook c8 now here I can
take with the pond I can take up the
knight also in fact taking what the
knight looks really really good I think
I just tinkled a night Chuck King e7 and
he's got no no squares
oh no Knights square so mercy a king e7
Brigade I'm just gonna play like Bishop
g7 I think yeah I just pick up this pawn
on e5 him he wins upon an e7 but I
picked this up and now everything's very
compact you're only pieces are really
well placed and I also maybe have worked
d2 at some point as well kingi - I'm
just gonna play f6 protect everything
solidify solidify basically everything
here in the center I could clear with d2
or if T to work F - I don't really want
to how do what's the easiest way to
finish this off and again because I
chalked a ton of time at the start I
have to play really fast here anyway
take took up the h2 pond bring the
bishop back and in fact action on top of
two pieces I also just have an extra
pawn now he's got two pawns I have three
so this is looking pretty good now
Knight h4 I'm gonna check him 90 for
Chuck you know like Keeney six maybe we
got Knight e5 Chuck next move if I can
if before I play Knight e5 Chuck King c3
I've got Knight b5 with the fork he need
three I can just move the knight I can
go see six I can go to f5 which one's
fast
I'm just gonna go to C to pick up the b4
pawn d4 Knight f4 king of five and
that's this this is just gonna be
winning five protect everything before
Jack now here comes the D pawn as well
it's got no Chuck so I can just play d3
Knight e3 and MP to ashes game
so all right so it's two for two so it's
a pretty good start
yeah you know going back to that games I
mean that was thought that probably was
not quite right I mean I probably I
shouldn't have played it like that I
mean like it's like if I go back to like
yeah like move whatever it was I mean it
probably yeah and this petition after
Bishop g5 just queen takes out five and
probably he can just resign on the spot
so it's taking on g5 is not not the best
way so I take just play point out five
minutes it's just over completely so
yeah not perfect technique but so what
two for two so on to the third round
so Bob Betty just subscribed with twitch
prime ok good to see again I'm pretty
new to this whole this twitch
partnership thing so I'm gonna see a lot
of these these alerts that I'm not super
familiar with what what they mean so
yeah I mean queen of queen of fire just
a very simple way to finish it
but anyway so far so good - 4 - um I I
don't really know I mean it's it's hard
to judge like I think this is just an
open tournament though so I mean I'm
wondering if in theory I could play
someone else who's on my team I mean I
don't know if that's possible or not I'm
not sure if that's possible or not but I
assume it is cuz it my understand is
this just a straight opener back I mean
I I don't know for sure if that's
correct but um but yeah so okay so I see
Greg writes yeah you can't play someone
else on your team so yeah so I guess
like I mean I guess probably that's a
good thing if it's later if it's early
that's probably a terrible thing but if
it's like route 10 or something you play
someone on your team that's probably a
good thing so it means they're doing
well I mean I should be doing well
generally so that probably means most
likely they're doing walls also so so
that would that would be that would be
good
and Dec writes arranged draws like a
true Soviet that won't be happening
actually I think one of my team members
I think is this Georgian this Georgian
guy mer galosh viele and actually I
think I beat him like 110 zero or 15/0 a
few days ago so so you know he's on my
team I mean obviously I'm gonna be out
to beat him so so if we play obviously
in the matches it's completely different
as well so you know I'll be be different
completely different so okay so it's 425
all right so I mean it's two rounds in
25 minutes so yeah this is gonna be
along at that actual this is and maybe I
shoulda like gotten some red Bull or
something for this event because it's
it's it's not gonna be short this
probably be like four or four or four
and a half hours I'm guessing and who
died also adding to the the joke says he
died for 400 rights wouldn't you like to
save energy by drawing I heard a sound
too this time okay so I'm playing X Y
soul six from China
I am so this guy's obviously probably
this guy's obviously very likely to be a
be honor raider most of Chinese players
who I've seen who are not you know the
top top guys they all or the up they all
are pretty good players there they're
definitely not underrated I can say that
it's all fake hey hey it's probably
gonna play point out six try to play
something like this well place eatery
try to try to just play chess basically
um aches
I'll take now I've got a slightly better
pawn structure so that's it's a good
start it's gonna be some kind of slow
endgame g5 will play off three play free
for maybe depending on what his next
move is I'm not sure so he plays c6 I
could play E for right away I think I
will I don't see a good reason not to
I'll take the e5 Knight h5 interesting
that was not what I was expecting
okay so here what are my advantage my
advantages are I've got these these dark
squares potentially um Bishop c4 looks
like a good move just go to the ship on
the diagonal stop f6 also maybe I mean I
Castle long or a castle short but
basically I think I really need to try
and use these these squares here in the
center as much as I can
now you could play Bishop e6 but if he
does I'll just castle
I think I'll Castle short probably I
could go long - it's just a it's I think
it's a preference thing so I'm gonna I'm
gonna Castle short because also hearing
now is Knight has no eye for square as
well so we're kDa off there okay D 1
because if he takes and I take okay but
now he goes 97 aha so he's quicker than
me to f5 okay so this is a slight issue
it's a 94 Knight f5 if I take and play
workout for I'm holding so I play 94 94
95 takes takes work out for b6 or
something not quite what I want but not
bad just play work up I'm just gonna go
for I'm gonna play 94 now you please not
have 5 all exchange and play work out
for maybe or maybe not actually wait if
I take work out for 90 or X takes work
out for 94 906 4 cups X uh it's a
mistake ok ok so I guess I have to play
workout for first done hopefully work
out for first that I still Knight f6
Chuck I plays 93 I still work c1 I'm
always keeping this knight f6 trick in
my back pocket
and as well I mean not only Knight f6
with maybe also Knight c5 I have a
couple different ideas here so so yes
we'll see so so we'll see what what he
wants to do here so now he's now he's
going into the tank try and figure it
out
and actually answer an earlier question
someone said - I think I'll go a 15 you
know I would say the answer is no
because there are several people in
Savannah who are who are quite quite
good I thought Daniel was playing for
example there's someone else really high
ranked as well so King g7 now that looks
like a mistake now I think I can take on
e6 he takes now go Knights e5 now I'm
hitting b7 and e6 at the same time
although it's still much reveal it's
this night it's it's a matter of time
bees like this Knight attacks d4 so this
night is very well placed but at the
same time if I can get my Knight to d6
and I'm doing very well - so I'm gonna
I'm gonna grab the pawn looks like the
right we were at d5 now I'm gonna go g4
I think because now I want to get my
Knight to d6 like if I can kick his
Knight I get my Knight to d6 like I'm
just winning whereas he really needs
this night to stay anchored here on f5
and once it comes off about 5 he gives
me d6 then the d4 pawn is no longer weak
and he's just down a down whole pond for
pretty much nothing if he goes Knight e3
then ok so he goes G fight so I could
take potentially or no I play warrock f5
takes takes on e5 paints is he has a pin
here on d1 say about rook f5 e FG
epidemic e5 so I can't do that
so please chief I so I think I just play
rookie for although then he has rook b8
maybe that must be his idea so let's see
do I have any other ideas here if I
think of the Pawnee just takes my rook I
think I kind of have to go rookie or
unfortunately my goes rook e8 e8 95 94
d4 whoopsie 547 ok this is gonna be some
kind of an end game I think I'm not
really sure what the actual evaluation
is but it's gonna but I'm definitely on
the right side of it so there's there's
a little to no risk okay but he goes
night each for which it's probably wrong
cuz now let's see so now he wants to go
to f3 me now my good idea since he goes
rogue f8 so I'm gonna go rook III I
think rookie 3 so I cut the f3 score off
from his night and I keep both
well c5 and e6 available for my knight
as well like if you plays rook b8 here
then I'm gonna go Knights e5 and hit the
e6 pawn so this is pretty advanced stuff
that I'm talking about so I'm having to
speak pretty quickly just because
obviously the game's ongoing so I can't
like gum okay so he plays the h5 so he
wants to create that v square for his
Knight now I could play each three then
he wants to take and go rook at Fiat
again probably but I okay I'll play h3
he'll take I'll take again this night
I'm controlling this f5 square which is
very very important here because it's a
basically the two nights and I've got
the extra pond but he was a knight you
sucks correctly I think and now the
question is how to proceed I'm gonna
play Knight d5 I think 95 now Knight up
for now now I have to start figuring out
how I'm good take advantage so I think
I'm gonna play okay I played be for you
is ricky ritp d8 but okay i'm gonna play
b4 here just start to expand a little
bit try it okay so he goes king g6
what does candy suxxx do i don't see the
point of that Lea gets off the I'll just
play Knight b3 protect protect protect
the pawn here she wants it over cage for
so I'll play with d2 we're gauge for
retreat array now that rook covers is e
2 square very importantly Brigade Road
eh ah but now I can't go ricochet 2 so
this is a problem let's see ok go King
off - okay Jay King III tricky
I'm gonna go King outs one so I still
virtue on AJ it's let's see okay now I
have to be very careful here so I'm
gonna play rook g1 Rick h2
go kini one 3d one start bringing the
swinging like king over now I could take
with the night I'll take with the thing
three
I'll take probably oh but now I actually
that's a mistake
yeah that was bad okay five maybe yeah
I've kind of miss played this rather
badly but I'm still I'm still in the
game oh this is bad okay I knew it fast
now it splits mode
he hung he hung that pond so I mean now
it's just not just to draw probably but
I still probably should try and play on
I mean yeah I've kind of miss played
this but such is life free pawn okay now
I get kini to chuck now he's gonna now
it's gonna be working I'm gonna get a
rookie cut tonight and pawn and this
game is gonna go on forever basically
because I'm gonna try to get it to rook
versus night I don't know if I'll be
successful but probably I won't be
successful but I'm still gonna try
now - maybe I can do something but I
mean it's very unlikely that I can do
anything
86 wait but now I go King out for now
let's wait a sec now it's getting a
little bit weird but still I can't do
anything here unfortunately so okay so
now I'm gonna have to get it it's gonna
be like rook versus night yeah somehow I
couldn't quite trick him but
unfortunately that's life and actually I
was I miss played it earlier as well so
wasn't any reason you know
let's see one was last capture last
capture was move was lost capture it was
II won so okay so this move 81 so they
slowed 131 and I have no illusions about
winning this but I'm gonna make him play
on as long as I can
because that's what you probably should
do in team events anyway so say yeah
that's last last little trick that there
was there now did he clean the drawer
without a draw automatically by the
server though I'm gonna assume that was
did he click the drawer was at the
server ID or not since out that was that
actually third 50 or was that more than
50 that was more than 50 okay so anyway
I wasn't sure about the rules in this
event either because because in the
normal games I think you have to claim
it
I think there also action and over the
board even it's not completely clear
what the rules are - I think it's
something like 50 minutes or 70 is it 50
moves or 75 I'm not sure what the exact
rules are but anyway
anyway next game XXY soul six
doesn't say a name for who this is hmm
actually I thought for this event you
kind of had to um actually list your
name officially but maybe not but anyway
so I'm actually was actually expecting
the next round to start right away since
I played such a long game on guesser
their other game still going must be so
anyway
anyway so far so good so three games two
and a half I'm guessing my goal is
something like I want to say thirteen
and a half is my goal probably three
draws and something like twelve wins
something like that that's that's
probably the my personal goal for this
of that or thirteen somewhere in that
range but around there okay so now I'm
playing another Chinese guy okay so I'm
playing all the Chinese today Korea I'll
just play solid for the moment see what
he wants to do I was expecting Bishop t2
and I just immediately put the fish back
on each sub that was not not very good
so I basically wasted a tempo but as
knights Londi - I mean probably this
obviously this isn't perfect but this
still might be relatively okay for me I
mean it's obviously I wasted a tempo but
I date but I still I'm not sure that
whites whites better obviously but I
don't know how much butter white can be
here Queen c2 c5 rook you wanna play row
c8
let's work see one I'm roughly Queen c7
here tried to bring my queen back to
like b88 I guess that's probably my idea
here
and even though I've lost the tempo I do
suspect that I'm relatively okay I mean
here basically the law stump was in my
works on fa not da for example like if
you look at the position where more or
less symmetrical at least this this
whole like D files on is symmetrical so
like Queen b8 we're both just getting
our Queen off the the C line here so CD
5 now I can take with the night I can
also take with the bishop I'm probably
I'm not gonna take with the pawn so I
want to take up the knight or not is
really the only question if I take with
the bishop he goes e4 anyway so yeah I'm
gonna take with a knight
I need 94 interesting ok so now I can
play h6 I can just bring the knight back
to f6 to be solid um rook FD 8 95 98
that looks ok takes but if he plays D c5
Knight c5 Knight g5 might be some issues
so h6 looks practical Knight f6 looks
like the most logical move to play here
but again I'm I'm not sure what the
situation is let me see like what does
it match so 7 out of 12 so actually team
is not doing great so here probably I'm
gonna try to play slightly unusual try
to keep the game very imbalanced if I
can so okay so I'm going to take on d4
keep it keep as many pieces on the board
as well yeah 7 out of 12 that's that
means that that means the rest my team -
did I think we were at I don't know what
we were at actually after after 8 games
so maybe not but then 7 out of 12
dropping 5 5 games probably is not not
great so I'm playin a put the clean on
this long diagonal
I just gave my EP five so now I'm gonna
go back to b8 cover the d6 square and
basically say what are you doing so this
has not been an optimal game and I've
thrown away like to Tempe already here
so it's often fantastic but here at
Queen e1 e six takes a b5 he's got he's
gonna have to move his Knight back so
I'm gonna kick the night from b5 first
and a knight c3 I'm just gonna play
Knight f6 or I can take this one takes
Bishop c3 Bishop a3 work d7 doesn't want
doesn't look ideal right up six no work
d7 so yeah I'm just gonna play Knight f6
so he plays Queen B 1 so now it's like
I'm trying to keep the game interesting
he's trying to I think just be as solid
as he possibly can here so it's gonna be
pretty hard here to do anything but of
course he also not just wasted tempos he
won Queen a one queen bee went back so
he gave me one of those one of those two
or three tempi that I already gave him
for no reason so positions pretty
balanced I will say that over overall
it's very balanced and I could play
Bishop f6 and the night II if I take
take 90 for Bishop b2 Rho C eight rooks
see a 96
I mean Knight f6 is a way to be just
very super Saul and I'm just gonna play
Knight f6 the positions - there isn't
enough position it's too balanced here
so it's hard to it's hard to play moves
that are not the absolute best moves
while keeping keeping some chances alive
without just ending up much worse Wow
okay I could have traded and probably
just made a draw on the spot but he but
again with the team at seven out or
twelve like probably here I'm gonna have
to have to do some stuff so Queen a1 I
can play that fade I could take a
play off six I don't like f6 I'm just
gonna play bish buff eight I think yeah
I'll just put this trough a alright okay
now I can take on CY I can play Queen
eight I think I will
take and play Queenie so again the
position is very solid here for both
sides but but now Queen B one I can play
Bishop a 3 B 5 doesn't look quite right
97 Bishop c7 look c8 takes takes f3 fish
baby I'm gonna go for I'm gonna try I'm
gonna try to play something masse here
although here E is Knight g5 maybe which
couldn't be a slight issue meaning
although he doesn't do it so you guys
fish bet three I can play knight c6 I
can play b5 there are many different
possibilities but he goes okay so I'm
just gonna play rook d7 get out of any
bishop c7 tricks here if Knight g5 now
I'll hit him with knight c6 attacking
it's official
probably help trade the bishops on b7
and I move this Bishop back still very
equal or to do anything but I mean maybe
I can create something here right so I
don't really want to take so I'm gonna
go get some beef bye-bye thank here now
if you take some might take with the
pawn I wouldn't say that it's guaranteed
but it's possible no that's like when
dat takes so it's still very hard to do
anything here so yeah it's probably all
I have to do it'll probably the only
thing I can do here is make a draw I
mean it's positions to to simplify
really for for anything else
Lindsay - I'll just play age six create
a square for my King probably try and
bring the knight back somehow open it7
here not not much I can really do if
he's trying to be super solid so just
how it goes sometimes
now final clean 84 I mean maybe I can
get a little something here I don't know
it's very unlikely I would say but maybe
I mean g5 III levy 5 or f5 actually g4
is no goats in against 95 so ok f6 and
teeny - probably chief or something like
that
it's real play h5 probably g4 like a 5
and I mean this is obviously very very
Grosh 96
I've got e4 d4 doesn't trap like my
bishop so okay now I'm getting something
here maybe I'm gonna get a bishop
against a bishop against a knight
probably play King e6 with E for
interesting okay so again probably this
is just a draw but I'm gonna keep trying
because again it's a team thing actually
what was 95 it's a bad note okay so I'm
after Spanish I'm gonna get a knight to
d4 but even if I get a knight to d4 is
it still still just a draw
yeah just just basically just a simple
draw a 5naf eye doesn't work yeah yeah I
mean that maybe that cam I should've
tried something more on Orthodox it's
hard than these these these matches it's
hard to know whether it's whether it's
you know what the right strategy is
whether it's better to be solid plate
play to win every single game but it's
it's it's tricky at times to figure out
what the right strategy is so anyway
that game there wasn't much I could do
the guy was just extremely solid on from
the start it's a very very dry opening
very dry position in jonno
so anyway spill as I said my goal is my
goal is 13 and a half or 13 so it was a
13 yeah I was basically I'm basically
figuring that I'm going to drop it but
I'm gonna drop one and a half or two
points hopefully only a draws
so again if you guys spending questions
let me know
croaks Proximus is king f7 instead of
king d6 by one king f7 he had Knight a6
attacking the pawn on c5 and maybe maybe
I still could draw but I mean like if I
go to f7 then he is 96 and c5 is weak I
mean besides these two weak pawns here
that that really basically prevent me
from from doing anything
so it looks like okay so the team has 9
out of 16 so again it's not looking so
so great at least at least so far
7 out of 12 9 out 16 17 and so cuz I
mean it's basically got two points
I don't know again it's it's hard it's
hard to it's hard to judge I mean like
I've not watched another game so I can't
really judge what's going on but I
figured basically I just have to have to
win at one game so I heard the board or
it sound so okay let's see so I'm
playing B Clark so I'll play the same
thing I'll just I'll just change it up
slightly that won't play the same same
setup although he's gonna play e5 takes
takes knight c6 probably in d2 just be
seven or g6 both are playable here 94 is
also possible
okay so good she took slow play c49
three out of three of the should be two
knocks and castles all pretty standard
Bishop d3 was also may be possible but I
prefer keeping the lights where bishops
on or all take take should I should be
careful not not to do it I did last
camps in this game it would be it would
lead to a direct loss so I'm gonna
castle here not I didn't take on g7 cuz
I don't want to give him this f6 where
for his cane war it's like he gets King
on g7 he can just play clean off 6 so
that's why here I just Castle and I'm
leaving the bishops on b2 in G sub
because I want him to take on v28 I
don't know what rook b8 does all this Q
now the question is works on c1 and do
you want or do you want to eat one I'm
gonna go for c1 and d1 with the rocks
just because I figure he played rook b8
so he probably wants to play for b5 at
some point he takes I'll take okay so he
takes I'll play Knight e5 I'll play
Bishop e2 just protecting the d3 square
you know six
I'm gonna go Queen d4 attack the pawn
here on a seven looks low play work ft1
g7 I'm just gonna retreat my queen
probably play e4 work c3 or f4 e for B
for several different ideas here but
they all seem reasonable so I'm gonna
play e4 now try to try to get some left
with my C rook maybe rook c3 work h3 or
works e3 e3 g5 interesting now I can
just go rook g3 enough for because of a
pin on the King here or h4 2 H 4 F 4 is
really the question here um now for
looks really interesting age I mean f4
knight c6 takes takes rook up one yeah
this house this has to be good she's
gonna go knight c6 here I'm gonna take
he's gonna take I'm gonna go broke up
one it feels like this King here is too
loose now with both these works on that
file in the G file it was like there's
got to be attacked
shot somewhere in here so he's probably
gonna go Queenie five yeah he does know
I can play Bishop d3 maybe that's it but
then he gets up six so probably I have
to go for something immediately so I
think I'm just gonna take its gonna take
on e4 there should be three queen e3 is
not what I want
Bishop h5 Queen e3 again not quite what
I want go to work at 5:00
Brooke at 5:00 rookie seven Queens e3
maybe this looks more along lines of
what I want but I'm still not sure
that's the best that I had here so I go
Queen c3 is going to work he's five he's
going work d5 no matter what so I can't
check him so if I move the bishop he's
gonna exchange Queens which I really
don't want Rick f5 is the only other
possibility we're cup five Queenie to
work up seventeen g8 Queen d5 doesn't
look quite right so or I can play work
out two also got to Queenie three point
d5 maybe that actually looks better now
that looks better now i protect the
bishop I keep I keep Queens on the board
too so on Queen III Queen d5 I'm hitting
off seven so this should be this rook F
to looks like the right move here so
rookie five
I'm gonna go rookie three we he'll
probably play rook e8 just gonna go
Bishop I'll see you before work f3 maybe
recovery first yeah work up three first
attack this pawn here on f7 now bishop
buff one just just get everything get
the defense set up because I mean black
king is so much weaker than White's King
with the Brooks on these F 2 F 3 squares
there's never really any danger here
so maybe he'll play Queen e1 or queen b1
I mean the good thing here is black does
not have much counter play like all this
pawn his pawns are fixed here you can't
really move is naive so really the only
counter plate has along the e-file here
so place queen g4 I could go rookie ch3
and try to checkmate him down the H file
possibly but I'm not crazy about so I'm
just going to a rook g3 I got and put
the rook on the G file so you can remove
the night so he goes back to e4 now I'm
gonna go Queen c3 c5 now that's an ugly
move now I'm gonna go over p3 because
now I created this backward pawn now as
pawns are really really ugly g6 no 22
put more pressure on d6
Queeny one I'll still just I'll just
munch the pawn on d6 here
so workout five okay so he wants to try
and exchange all the works now I can go
rookie to I could also just take and I
mean I'm just up a pawn right but maybe
it's some drawing chances then he's
gonna go Queen off six I play rookie -
what - see it's gone Queen up for right
okay so do I really have a choice here
or not is the other question I don't
think I do so okay so I'm just gonna
take and I'm just gonna grab the
material probably he'll trade the rooks
maybe not but probably I assume he's
gonna go clean up six and then I have a
big choice if I want to go for an
endgame or not but he plays 95 so he
wants to go Knight g4 so I'm just gonna
play play each to reprove on it I could
also just bring my queen back to like d2
which i think is what I'm gonna do just
bring the Queen back don't worry about
these pawns over here and then now I can
just play Age 3 just cut off the g4
square goes up five no so like I should
nicely there's B - take off - now King
f6 I think of g3
yeah it looks like I've got g3 here
knight c6 Bishop a3 you need five now h4
King g7 I don't really want to play g4
here though but if I take doesn't work
so let's see okay so I take he's just
gonna play Knight a 4
so what to do what to do I think I'll
play it anyway age 4 now I can check or
I can take I'm just gonna take the Queen
e3 is gone Knight h3 so how do we do a
little bit careful here so the Bishop g4
actually I should probably just start
blitzing him I'm being very slow for
some reason today which has not been a
good thing
Chuck now h5 maybe 9h 425 maybe I don't
know if this works I might be a
perpetual here though now I can blog
okay hang out 7h 5 IE 7 h6
you know five this should just be a
wedding because now I can use the now I
can just bring my king in can can just
come all the way up here so 2495 king c6
and it's just all boy yeah okay alright
so that's
okay so okay so that's another one down
so I guess actually I can also see the
standings as well probably I assume or
not no it doesn't is there or actually I
can or no I can't I can only just see oh
it just looks like okay so I can't
actually see the standings here so so
basically I just have to play my game
and then hear from the manager as far as
what the overall scores are so okay so
we scored three and a half out of four
that means we're at twelve and a half
out of 20 which shouldn't mean we're
somewhere near the top I'm gonna take a
guess
so
so yeah so so what do I have I've three
out of four I think 3 wins 2 draws so
pretty decent result not not great not
you know not terrible obviously with the
super hydrating and any kind of non
perfect results you know lead to losing
a bunch of points but that's not really
a big deal so ok so let's let's see
sorry soon a next round it's probably
gonna start soon as my guests but I'm
not sure
really paying attention to the trout
obviously just it's not um not not
during the games I think I actually
talking probably a little bit too much
as well because a couple of these games
I should have should have been able to
press them and I have one much much much
easier than I did so hasn't been great
so far but still three out of four
pretty decent result obviously team team
results is much more important um so
okay so so far so good so today here the
board yeah I did hear the board okay so
now I'm playing Danya so now it's a
tough spot because now I don't know what
I'm supposed to do whether I'm supposed
to try and beat him or not be him but
okay he's gonna play b3 he was gonna
play B through them then yeah then I'm
gonna take a shot I was expecting down
here to play something more normal but
he's gonna try and play my opening
against me so this is gonna be
interesting
Aurel played Bishop g7 castles probably
fish b2 or t3
maybe d4 all possible play e4 clean
eighty six and running possible is I'm
just gonna play easy for the knight c6
off from exchange of the Knights
d3 as expect it I'll take X plate t5 it
please see if I don't place c5 here
again just trying to develop the dish
phone it's long diagonal
so let's see what's the I was gonna take
continued so please Quincy to so I can
play a 94 he's gonna go a 95 play work
he ate but I like Knight g4 I'm putting
the knight on e5 here I mean I expect
him to play Knight e5 but I'm not he
could play h3 I suppose eh 395 there
should be two Queen g5 it's not not not
not really clear for either side it does
play age three now if I play Queen h4
it's probably just a draw so I'm going
to 95 it's before now do I want to play
c6 or not that's question number one if
I play c6 he's gonna play Queen d2 and
then if I play Queenie 7f 497 why not
let's see it so Queen d2 I'm going to
play Queen e7 is up for first
interesting seven one seven two hit the
bishop here on e for 188 I've got the
eight now basically you can play you for
not plea for that's really the question
here
the place clean up - so he really wants
to play e4 he doesn't want to do it
right away so I mean he's like he's
trying to say he's gonna play e4 next
move so I think I'm just gonna play
Knight update so now I protect us get
the night off the D file now if he goes
efore iv6 d 494 I could take I could
also just play d5 d5 takes takes an f6
Knight c3 d4 DD 4 takes takes written
sub and ok this is interesting so I can
play off 6 if I want to f5 is also maybe
a move actually but I don't know if I
really want to play off 5 here so let's
say so 94 d5 takes the e4 is a move no
that's not a good
now I'm trying to just come hold the
right idea here five take 6 e 4 I think
I'm gonna go for it here I'm gonna play
off 5 plays Knight c3 okay interesting
I have four okay so we're kind of just
dancing here a little bit it's about six
given the exchange he wants I mean
that's still very equal probably I mean
again it's gonna be hard to to do
anything here but he plays Queen d2 it's
interesting now I think I'm just gonna
no I'm just gonna take I'm gonna play d5
my mom and ask him what he's doing here
Queen e5 is maybe a move please rook c1
so I can play d4 if I want again it's
gonna be very hard to win this the sit
position just so dry that's that's the
problem it's very hard to create play if
your opponent trying to play very very
safe probably is gonna take I assume
Acheson okie five I have worked d2 right
let's work e2 now I'm gonna play like a
king queen before maybe or just queen
before right away
I'm queen before right away makes sense
our Forks a4 go ahead Queen d2 maybe wow
they'd be amazing if I do I think I do I
hope I'm not wandering something here
but I think I do have this move
Brooksie two's oslo can't I just take
the rope here vertices seven enough to
and work d1 game over yeah yeah so clean
off six was not I mean he could have
played rook c2 but but I mean already it
was a little bit on the wrong side here
like right around here after Queen d2
you could he could have gone work see
tubes then I go queen bee one Queen off
one Queen D one King H two point off one
with the idea of work d1 so it's it's
tricky so okay so that's that was an
important win so I'm gonna run to the
rice and quickly I'll be back in a
second you guys hopefully the game
doesn't start in the next like thirty
seconds but I'll be back in the back
[Music]
okay everyone so all right so it doesn't
look like the game started so um see ya
so I guess okay so now I'm on I guess
five out of six so two draws four wins
that was an important win cuz Daniels
pert pretty pretty strong I'm you know
the guys in this event who I who I would
put right up there he's him and uh I
think the you yang ye the China pander
or panel I don't know what his name is
on chess calm but but both of them are
um are probably two guys who I would say
are the most dangerous players so that
was an important win so okay so five out
of six but you know we're still not even
halfway through this event yet so it's
gonna be a long long at that
um so I see Alan n CH has kreitzer
dangerous yet they get rekt by he Carter
time after time I mean yeah and
technically that's correct but when I
say dangerous I mean they're guys that I
could lose to is more what I'm saying is
that if if I make like a blunder or
slight mistake that I could very easily
lose to those guys and and so even if I
in general I'm gonna beat them the vast
majority of the time especially in an
event like this today we're like it's
very important not to not to drop points
it's obviously there that's why I say
they're very dangerous because
expression is not like today they're not
the guys you want to play because
because then you can you can end up in a
lot of trouble and losing a game is
pretty pretty disastrous I think I mean
for me at least in this event when the
team I think they really need me to put
up a big squirt up shot to qualify so so
so yeah so alright so once I'm you know
I guess actually maybe I can see the
games can I see the games here so I can
see no so it doesn't look like I can
actually I was trying to figure out the
setup here is like title Tuesday but it
doesn't look like I can actually see the
see the see the see the see the game is
going or any of that stuff so so yeah so
I mean I'm just gonna keep sitting here
chillin watching your your comments come
through um I see a few questions here
and there like George BOE it says so
what's your favorite food on and I think
it depends it's a big mix um if we're if
we're talking in general I mean I would
say for sure Japanese is obviously my
favorite um big fan big fan of sushi
sashimi um look this a little raw fish
thing I also like like ramen quite a bit
even though that's ramen a new dome the
noodles it's starting to get a little
bit off the healthy side into the
unhealthy stuff but I still like like
all that um
I also like Italian obviously big thing
on a big fan of pasta a lot of different
sauces that I'm big kind of as well I
mean like probably my favorite for the
most part stuff like carbonara
for example or like a nice Puttanesca
sauce had intended lean more towards
those are probably my favorite ones are
the more like northern Italian more
Americanized stuff I mean obviously
there's very generic stuff like
spaghetti and meatballs just with like a
generic tomato sauce but a bit of
everything so that's probably my second
um I moved beyond that I would have to
say my third its it's really close I
like ethnic food a bit so probably I
would probably I would say it's tough I
like Thai but ty in general there I'm
very limited like I'm a big fan of the
yellow curry you know I like ma saman
for example or what's the other one yeah
or a red curry I mean those are probably
what I tend to stick to maybe there are
other things too like sautee for example
which I like as well but but but I'm
pretty limited like I have certain
things that I really like in Thai where
it's like in India and I like just about
everything like SOG for example just
thinking of something obviously I like
chicken tikka masala like the core Mo's
are pretty good as well
I love naan so I mean I love all the
stuff that of course you know can't
can't eat that stuff every day because I
think it was it was Kramnik who who who
decided once that like he really loves
Indian food but anytime he eats Indian
food he gains two kilos so so obviously
to control yourself anyway I heard that
heard the board start so I'm playing
against real boy now so I see Lane r00
donated $10 Thank You Lane art
appreciates a donation this game I'm
gonna play I'm gonna play a practice
game it's a Nike to 0.96
so excited it's gonna be pretty Stan
Knight of four I thought Knight f4 here
is considered dubious maybe I'm wrong
did I confuse the lines let me think
seven so we're gonna exchange Queens
here okay so he takes on f6 first so if
I take on eh five you want to take on g7
I can take with the palm but it's not
quite right so I'm just gonna play
Knight of six he's gonna take on out of
seven change the Queens Knight of 356
pretty standard position he has 95 here
but I just go teeny 7 castles gonna play
rook e8 why not a complete Bishop d7 or
King g8 even maybe even just a 5 here
just to simplify you know I think I am
just gonna play e5 just simplify it
right away again it's gonna be hard to
win the suits and positions very
simplified but again when you're black
it's failure you're not always gonna get
what you want it's hard to it's hard to
on four sets sometimes so take but of
course an equal position is also
completely fine just generally there are
certain sort of positions like this
where it's it's gonna be hard to win
although I'm I think I'm gonna get some
chances hopefully so there should be
five I can play Bishop d7 but I think
I'm just gonna play rook e7 sidestep the
bishop 93 hopefully Bishop d6 there's
about four now I could take one out
there some way not to take though but
now I don't really see I'm gonna have to
exchange so I'm gonna take and play like
maybe g5 fish about five something like
that but he takes I think this was
slightly wrong because now I'm gonna get
my king to d6 they're just probably
where I want my king actually there's
about five I mean I think I want my king
here on
this is closer to my pond 53 now I can
take I don't really want to but hard to
do anything so yeah I've got it just
taken probably unfortunately this is
gonna be a draw as well but I'm
definitely not going to take a draw not
not in a team team situation for sure
this was just a normal blitz key and
there's a reasonable chance that I would
that I would consider it not that I
necessarily would do it but that it
would be a real consideration so let's
see so Ricky - so if I play 97 off 395
and it's gonna be hard to do on anything
here but I feel I feel like I really
need to try since I do have this Center
pawn I mean I do have this this pawn in
the center it should count for something
- oh if I go b6 he has a go be 60s
before I actually overlooked that that's
that's pretty bad so okay so he wants to
please and you know this is interesting
so I do have my king here on d4 so let's
see so so yeah I mean I don't really see
how I can do anything though so I'm just
going to offer a draw because he can
just kind of wait here so probably
neither of us can do anything I think
but you might try to play on I I don't
know I when I went 95 was in ago b6 I
just forgot that he had a he had d4
there I was just a terrible oversight on
my part so what to do
[Music]
but he's obviously thinking about it so
I mean I assume he's gonna play on no
we're not okay so he just takes the draw
fair enough
yeah it's kind of hard to do something
here I mean it's like probably hair is
white can create a passed pawn with this
three versus two majority if I try to
like run my came over to see for B 4 B 3
somehow like I can try a5 a4 a3 type
things but it doesn't really work like
for example oh maybe I can make moves
but like yeah actually because King Ditu
like if I just even if we reached
something like this for example just
doesn't exempt herb b6 like even
something like this I mean even
something like this is not probably not
winning so now he's up for my go King
see two egos King III and once we come
back Leigh if I go d4 then he goes d1
and she before g5 v it's it's very very
fast so it's kind of kind of hard to do
anything here but yeah that's not not
not ideal but okay that's that's life
[Music]
so
so anyway yeah so okay so so three
drawers
we've played what seven rounds I guess
I'm starting to lose track now it's like
I think we played seven rounds but yeah
so all right so back to some questions
okay Allanon chests as yogacara ever
been to the Mechanics Institute NASA if
any plans to hit it um yeah actually I
have been to the mechanics I played a
tournament there in 2004 I think it was
it was a long time ago I played a played
a lady nor a grandmaster norm tournament
there so so I have played the mechanics
before that was a long time ago but it's
a good term I did quite well I think I
came up a little bit short of a norm I
think but I enjoyed it there and I think
I was there a couple of years ago as
well one time but but just in general
but but just in general I mean I love
San Francisco so I I haven't been there
I haven't been there much lately but I
mean in San Francisco itself I'm a huge
fan so probably next time I go out if
there's an opportunity though the
mechanics I will so sparkly marquee says
do you listen to music while playing on
it depends sometimes I do right now I'm
not going to just cuz I think if I
there's no other I put on music it's not
going to be a playlist like in iTunes or
anything that's probably gonna be in
YouTube so I I that's gonna slow down
the stream and all that other good stuff
but it really depends in general I do
listen to music usually not Ted phones
usually I just play the music on my
computer but in general I tend tend to
prefer playing with music than without
guru Basque writes how do you your
fantastic chess ability to transpose in
everyday life I mean that's interesting
question I think I mean I think there
are some things that do and some things
that don't so you know that I'll get
into that another time but there are
some things that I think do translate
directly there are a lot of things that
don't someone else writes did you paint
ex-convict 15 I hope you're not really
an ex-convict but anyway um if you uh he
he asked if I painted the wall behind me
no I did not paint the wall behind me it
was like like that when I when I bought
this house um I might change the color
sometime but the painting takes a lot of
time and generally when I'm around at
least here in Florida I don't tend to
have a lot of time to do that so uh oh
so generally uh John junk generally I
mean that that would be a real project
for painting I mean I'd have to dedicate
like a couple of days at least probably
close to a week and generally I don't
tend out a lot of time so it's not
something that I would uh so one second
so so yeah anyway okay so back to the
games
I guess that game was a pretty quick
draw so probably there gonna be a bunch
of game still going right now um so
let's let's see so I see after the last
murder tied for third with fifteen and a
half out of 24 so the team is doing
pretty well I mean I would have liked to
have won this last game but still I was
black it's not not not so easy on and
life goes on and of course there's so
many more rounds I think that's that's a
bright round II round eight I think I
think I've drawn three and one five no
maybe not if I had five out no I had one
for drawing three so I guess that's
seven something like that
you keep track anymore it's been a lot
of games now so so we'll see Proxima so
that's how long were you in plank
outside so I've been playing since I was
seven so seven is probably a bit old now
for starting I think most people should
start when they're not should start but
gentlemen when they're a little bit
younger anyway I see Ron round eight has
started so okay this game I'm gonna play
something a little bit different I'm
playing oh I'm playing mirage kochenko
here so okay let's see what he wants to
do play gnomes oh let's see
c5 Oh Cal plating which one do I want
I'll just clean that g2 here three
probably he'll take although now that I
mentioned this if you played goes back
this is actually turning it's actually
turning into a game I had at that event
in San Francisco at the mechanics where
I had this position with white against
Walter brown all those years ago so it's
actually something I'm a little bit
familiar with so a5 a5 looks wrong
somehow I'm 94 96 might be six yeah I
feel like 85 is not the move there so
that's let's see what he's gonna do here
he's not ft 7 I'm gonna play I'd c3 just
develop on pieces before this was always
there but I didn't really like it so now
I'm gonna play Bishop b5 now if you
please b6 I always I'm gonna have some
c6 stuff he's gonna have some some
issues
he goes for it anyway Wow okay thought I
was not expecting now I can play b4 if I
really want to which I might which I
might do I'm not sure yet or I'll play
c6 but I really want to play c6 but I
don't actually see it working right off
so I'm just gonna play p4 and and ask
him what he's really trying to
accomplish here so you can take on c5
I'll probably take with the b-pawn I can
take with the D pawn also they're both
possible on this question of which one I
like well I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
play it more more on the interesting so
I try to make it more in balance so I'm
gonna table the D pawn so as Bishop f6
now I'm gonna go work a3 I think
or just Bishop d2 I'm not sure which one
which one makes more sense or was your B
- I'm gonna play rook III I think I like
work a 3 goes night a 6 now I could take
and play b5 can't I be 5 because b5
takes Knight d5 Queen e5 Knight c3 I'm
just up a piece I think now it's not
that was the best when maybe the Bishop
d7 Knight b6 was actually better but
yeah it takes oh I've taken the Knights
if I take with the rook then ok so now I
want to play work a6 because now if I
after work a6 take 6 b5 he can take 6
and play Queen a5 so that's what this is
what he wants but now I'm just gonna
Castle and once he takes on the a3 if I
get the bishop to a through then it done
it then it protects both these pawns and
I can just start marching the pawns
right up the board at the same time I'm
also now threatening to just take the
rook on a6 and play b5 so if I take and
play b5 u as Queen c5 so that's what he
wants so I can play Queen e2 maybe yes I
like Queen e2
please cleaning some so if I take take
b5 again I'm gonna hang c5 so I could
take and play Queen a2 or gate is always
there or I can just play Queen a - yeah
cleaning - looks pretty simple
takes Bishop a three and then B five
again b5 b6 all the same same ideas I
could have played Queen a3 but I like
the bishop here more on a3 just because
it's a great diagonal here and also the
more piece I can keep on the board the
stronger I think these two pawns are
gonna be it's 95 b5 is here there's some
reason why b5 is not good goodnight b5
night or just b5 night see for a one
queen a v b3 yeah I don't see it why not
and after 94 I can also play Bishop b4
Navy so there are a lot of lot of
dangerous ideas here for Wyatt I think
plays Knight c4 so I can play Bishop b4
and c6 I mean this is a question I want
to go Bishop b4 or not there should be
four takes takes e5 c6 Ricky a 93 Bishop
e6 Rick a one okay one Queen a five
point III this would be smoky and z6 I
think R okay wants the right move to
play here so I'm gonna play with a one
so now it's it's pretty okay so queen a5
is what I expect now I'm gonna go Queen
b3 and he still has problems developing
this bishop you can't push five son he
hangs his D pawn so I mean he really
needs us diagonal for this for this
light square bishop and okay please
ninety-two now I know I can play Queen
before I think Queen before so right now
so offer the exchange of the Queen's he
probably has to take it was d4 which I
kind of expected now I could place c6 as
a bad note 92 Knight b3 work you won d3
Knight c3 gets out of it so I'm just
gonna play 81 here now he's going to put
the knight on c4 e for I mean if he
doesn't go to c4 though he's probably
just lost cuz then then them both pawns
just run right up the board but if he
goes to c4 I can also just play rook c1
and force tonight off off of that square
so he does he actually just resigns I
think he realized that it's probably
just just losing so I know that's that's
a good win um so now yeah now that but
now now that's a brown so still I mean
it's still we're barely even halfway
through so so a long way to go long way
to go
anyway getting back to the questions
anything else
4:44 writes Hikaru why does chest' calm
rating matter so much it doesn't
actually matter that much
oh I'm not sure why who died seems to
think it's in general I mean it's it's
nice obviously never really high rating
but in reality it doesn't make make much
of a difference in other news use of its
rights have you ever been to Ireland yes
I've actually I've been to double and
only one time but I really liked it when
I was there as a short short visit it
was two days but but just going to the
heart of Dublin the centre is really
really nice really happening town
obviously with with with the tax laws
it's become a bit of a bit of a haven a
place for a lot of foreign investment so
it's it's definitely a place that has
become you know very very very nice city
and place that I think that I hope to
get back to again soon so I I really
enjoyed being in Dublin for those few
days
so okay so still obviously a bunch of
games going um someone wants to know
where my next turn is my next event okay
so obviously I'm playing this event
today if we qualify which hopefully we
do all I'll be playing in this a few
more times um but my next event
okay I'll be playing Fabiano in the air
um sorry in this the the blitz splits
battle event on November 2nd I believe
it is the second or the fourth I'm not
100% sure um and then after that I'll be
going to Palma my orca to play in the
feed a Grand Prix event from November 14
to 25th and then after that I'll go to
London for the London Trust classic to
finish off the year so alright let's see
okay so okay so 20 and a half out of 32
so I assume that means we have another
very good round on the team did at least
so doing pretty well so far
we're pretty good pretty good I mean I
assume at some point I'm gonna have to
play play play Pando I mean whatever his
name is that someone someone who'd just
tell me um a chest panel that's what it
is chest Panda I assume at some point
I'm gonna end up playing against him but
it's weird so I've already played to
Chinese so if I play a third one they
must be all be doing pretty well which
means probably it's gonna be very hard
to get to first but second and third
should still be there I'm in regards to
a few of the other questions I'm not
going to be answering questions about
about about the president I feel like
politics at least at least for a moment
I don't feel like discussing politics on
this this stream right now so I'll be
willing to talk about in regards to
specific issues at another time but but
right now I'm not gonna be talking
talking about that at all
so ICD are fun writes why are you
playing on Seattle's team I'm playing on
Seattle's team because I play for the
sluggers in the the former US Chesley
which has now become the approach House
League a few years back I also lived in
Seattle for a brief period in 2010 or
2009 sorry so so I'm I'm very close with
Seattle I was out
a couple of months ago as well and I
just felt like playing for them again
and I'm trying to help them recall if I
obviously they're one of those teams
that they they have they haven't had a
lot of Block in the league so I figured
it made sense to come back and play for
them again and try to try to help them
out as best I can
but of course we need to qualify today
first before for anything else really
matters fairly sure rights have you ever
tried learning oh yes I did I have
played go actually a fair amount but but
I wouldn't say I'm any good at it so
okay so here's the big match or who
wants to see some playing just Panda one
two three on I guess I have more points
in it now somehow say please d4 I'm
obviously this game he's gonna be
extremely solid against him I think I've
gotten black I've heard on black against
all three Chinese players or only two I
think no actually I got white against
the first guy so it's just the glass so
I think I've gotten black against so
playing a very topical wine I've
actually had this against him before
so this is following my game against
targets in from from the isle of man
tournament
so we'll see one six this is all pretty
pretty normal so far be five interesting
I guess I've played this day three we
need to now how to take advantage of
this light square or a dark square
weakness I should say not sure there is
a way to take advantage so I'm just
gonna treat my Bishop back to update
plays h4 play wait g6 it's gonna go h5
obviously alright
please pick up t2 which I kind of
expected
I play Queen c70 is going to play off
for undoubtedly then I'm done let's see
like in d7 here you can play out five
but I'm just gonna take the pawn
this vision before I'll play rook c8
King takes I could have taken with the
Brook but I want the rook on the C file
it is an open file and I don't feel like
White has any serious attack coming here
although here maybe you can actually
take on g6 okay doesn't take please rip
d2 now if I take on h5 YZ plays Bush
page 7 I presume so let's see so if I
played Bishop h5 what is his idea if I
just play Bishop h-bar display Bishop
off one
now he wants to go out 5 ok but now I
think I think I have some chances here
to create something so let's see
maybe I should have played it the other
order actually so now he has dish buff
one maybe okay working up to now
now let's see okay yeah five Queen h6 g5
Queen g5 Queenie five
yeah I don't see it so let's see so g5
Queen eh sure I've got Queen a5 actually
so this is very imbalanced and actually
for that reason I'm a little bit
surprised he went for this because I
feel like in this sort of position like
the two weaker guys on his team have
actually um they've actually drawn me so
for the team from a team standpoint he
draws me too it's quite good as well
because I will have played three
therefore players on the bottom to have
drawn but he obviously wants to play
aggressively and try it and he's trying
to beat me but I'm not sure that this is
a is actually good for white back I'm
very skeptical that this is this is okay
so he goes Queen g3 so now I can play
there many possible is I think I'm just
going to play h6 protect the pawn here
on g5 actually I couldn't go on Queen 85
to force Queen g5 and then gone Queen e5
you got a transposition so age six was
actually a bad move
stills protect the pond here so I mean
white does have to come up with
something right away here please be four
so you just you he wants to take away c5
and he prevents me from doing anything
so play I have six here I can play rook
t1 not that I like either move
particularly I think I'm just gonna play
five and say what are you doing
although if I play 85 then he goes clean
h2 so that's actually clean h2 is a real
threat here so maybe here I will start
to place play I will play something else
so I play I have six you're just gonna
take I feel like there's a d1 that looks
very weird but it might work I don't see
a reason why it doesn't way isn't
playable so I'm gonna go for it I mean
it looks like a very weird move because
I mean this looks very weird but it
doesn't look like it's terrible so you
guys have sex
he still has no actual threat though so
now I'm gonna play eight or wait now I
can't play each what am i doing yikes
yikes yikes yikes
ghoulish before he's clean eh - so I've
got to be very careful here with how I
play this so I think I'm just gonna
start sidestepping I'm just gonna run my
King start running my came over if I can
it's about five logical move go stay for
an a300 shoot does that oh yeah I coin a
fort ah oh yeah yeah oh man did I just
blunder that I wow that was just
terrible wonder that completely yeah it
was completely winning for me wow that
was terrible
Wow Wow even at the end Queen yeah even
at the end Queen c4 is probably okay
Queen c4 hi yeah even at the on Queen c4
Bishop d3 Queens 3 no but I mean really
the problem was I played h6 after Queen
g30 Queen a 5 were just completely
winning cuz after Queen a5 he had to
take and then I get Queen g5 25 and the
point being that like when I played g5
if he takes on g5 I go Queen e5 and it's
the position I wanted and after Queen G
or actually maybe Queens you through
Queenie of 5 he is b4 maybe yeah somehow
it wasn't so simple though ok if I go
back to the game almost see okay so if I
go back to the game p4 Bishop d1 fills
are on yeah maybe not fish bait for here
somewhere like right here like Queens
see Queen b5 or Queen it's it's a tough
position to play I mean I'm sure black
is probably winning here but there's
slot um there's a lot it's kind of messy
it's not it's not simple to play and you
know after Bishop a4 queen a3
I mean Queen Seif I mean Queen C 626
doesn't work cuz then he goes b5 and
he's turning track me it on e7 i thinkin
queen c5 28:43 hang up her king of three
work out for me
gingy three Queen e5 kingi for work out
one very
very messy non knock there b6 King f8
yeah this is all very messy very very
messy but basically I mean it's somehow
it feels like yeah right around here
it maybe even maybe yeah maybe her
instead of Bishop d1 but but I mean he
is too running Queen h2 that is a real
threat here but maybe here just f6 for
example is possible many many
possibilities but again it's a long long
event things are gonna happen so it's
not yeah and yeah it's actually yeah
like we recruit c2 is not possible to
yeah I mean both both ideas don't work
work see Brooke c2 doesn't work there's
Bishop c2 and rook f1 doesn't work as
takes Bishop b5 Bishop d3 and and yeah
that's yeah just uh maybe but ok so Sona
Bishop a4 actually like even hear me
because white does not have problem is
it's hard because you feel like White's
always threatening EE 6 or something but
white actually has no threats here and I
feel like even here maybe maybe
something like in d8 or I don't know
like it's it's just a tough position to
play and it's it's it objectively it's
easier to play for white than black if
both players have no time so there there
are yeah unfortunate but still a long
way to go
there's prey for Queen a3 other there's
probably nothing I mean even yeah there
was nothing after Bishop a4 just a just
a bad move though I mean still I
should've played Queen C for Queens
before to force Bishop d3 at least yeah
but it's okay that's all it's all losing
you guys so okay ah
yeah that was that was pretty bad but
anyway no I'm not a big deal still six
rounds to go this is later in the
probably I would have I would have
avoided something quite this dangerous
like he even here for example after
Queen upped who yeah but also actually a
big mistake here was that I that I
didn't then throw in the check first
like after a five I should've checked
first cuz any has to go to h2 and then
after I go Queen d5 it's a much better
version like we have four g5 for example
eg three h6 and it's it's much to run
the King on eh - and this pawn always
being checked whites whites just much
more it's probably just lost actually so
that was that was pretty bad I mean I
just I just played in the wrong order
when I in the game so it's very
unfortunate but what to do what to do
and so as was that was that round nine
or eight or ten which one was that I
think that was around nine Mimi I think
was wrong
I maybe I'm getting confused but yeah
it's any at any rate it's been a long
while a lot of games so okay next game
so okay
wrong time this game only be fast avoid
any time pressure that's also important
as well just to be very quick in general
probably Knight a5 Bishop e7 to invoke a
94 some kind of theory that I'm unaware
of so takes he'll take up three Houdini
donated $5 Thank You Houdini for the
donation I appreciate it
now if he takes 9423 for Knight f6
Queens you for Knight f6 Queen f3 is
interesting but I think here I'm just
gonna play simple trust just develop
keep keep keep the game flowing these
fast more importantly it's about sex
okay
it wants to exchange the bishops office
cows all item exchange the bishops d6
now here like he'll take with the night
I assume Queen f6 allows 95 lady through
an e4 next if I can
there should be six la 93-94 got the
salt move can be to take stinks so I'm
quite slightly better here
good night that Bishop blacks a slightly
worse pawn structure but by no means is
it is blocking like serious trouble it's
gonna be a long position where or what
it tries to grind seven so I'm gonna
play Ricky one maybe I'll play chief or
maybe I won't maybe I'll just play Queen
g3 and try to put a rock on g3 or sorry
queen g3 and put a knight on off five
something like that or put a piece on g3
and put a knight on that five maybe
seven three seven tonight it's four of
g5 I can retreat my queen or play rook
g3 rookie five no I'm gonna rip g3 X now
it's ready to take on f6 and now I've
also got Knight a5 as well
okay now I really want to play nine to
five and then it goes Bishop cheese six
and I'm kind of out of moves again like
to start all over again so I'm gonna
play Knight up to three just force the
rock off of this nice e5 square and try
to play play maybe Queen h4 yeah I think
click Queen h4 so now when I move my
knight away I don't know if I'll go H to
g4 or some other concept but both these
pawns are extremely weak and black and
never go vision p6 because I don't take
because I've got the pen of honest King
on h8 here so rook e8 now here how to
agreement over the knight is really the
question so I think I'm gonna play
Knight I want to go night h2 bunny has
Bishop e6 I like maybe I'll just play
Knight d2 cuz now I protect you for in
case he plays d5
so he plays d5 but now I've worked off
sex dough and I or not birkoff's xde 494
request 6d 494 24 work up to 64 94
rookie for TE for uni for work f2
it's Eve for coming for okay what am I
missing what am I missing
[Music]
pom pom pom ah takes night 55 no I don't
see it I don't see it so hopefully I'm
not hanging hanging everything here
hopefully that's also the drawback is
again like if the scheme was not the
last game for example if you don't lose
the game it's much easier to just play a
move like that right away but after you
lose the game you're like oh my god am I
missing something I forgetting something
all these kind of bad thoughts enter
your mind so rotation 648 so I can take
or not take um I can probably just plain
Knight f3 Knight g5 maybe maybe probably
not so here I should probably just play
something safe and stable so I'm just
gonna play work up to cuz now my route
now I work protects d3 as well so it was
c3 my Knight f3 I could Knight of three
takes Knight g5 Knight a form was also
no Knight if one just hung e4 that
wasn't possible bad move so I'll
probably take and I'm gonna go Knight g5
six month like you know for I think
right and Chuck me it on a feet and you
can't play execute here cuz Queen update
is Chuck me
it was queen deflatable or a hope well I
was just about to blunder mate and once
okay so - so it was King g8 I take what
the pawn or the night probably take the
night though I take the night I'll work
up seven I've got to be very very
careful again I move my work to like e
to
very very tricky very very very tricky
position to play again I'm getting too
long time so probably just got to stop
talking to you guys for a bit
son of a queen see one
and now I'm going to reach a non-games I
should win this one
and now it's too many pawns it's just
I'm gonna be up to pawn seriously
slowly draw or not I'm not sure I don't
think this is a draw but it could be
wrong okay now it's just winning so I've
got 86 87 well I was also really really
tough hmm that's almost have been easier
than what I did though somehow like
right around here okay if I go back so
tanks go to this position
yeah chief I was wrong when I should
have done here as I should've played
rook b6 King g7 Merc a sex then rip c3
yeah rook c3 then I can play rook e6
with the pawn on g4 it's very easily
winning cuz now I can go rookie 14 you
five and just run my king all the way
over because what I did in the game I
think it was actually maybe a draw I'll
go back to right around yeah right
around here yeah right around here I
think work out for was a draw maybe if I
go 85 then he then he has rook f5 and
it's the Vancouver position that's va-nc
you are a you can look it up on
Wikipedia I think but I think we're okay
for is a draw here but anyway okay next
games no I'm playing ellingsworth round
11 okay what do I want to play okay this
time all I'll get back to playing
unusual stuff because I feel like I
probably should have been doing this
early on so we her guys and then I
stopped doing it so takes
probably councils our Knight c3 c4
Knight c3 both are possible c4 okay
seven castles seven go play rook e8 just
to make sure there are no d5 ideas I'm
gonna play Knight h5 I actually like 9 h
5 why not three reasonable move play
Bishop d6 you have Knight f4 I'm worried
about c5 maybe so I'll just bring my
knight backed off six one gosh my fate
again opening up this e line for my rook
5 now now I have to be a little bit
careful so now I'm gonna play a queen
seat maybe here maybe g6 looks wrong so
I'm gonna quickly see a basically I also
might want to play for c5 here as well
depending on the situation
putting my bishop on f8 was wrong
probably my I fill up my this funny
seven and had my night on f8 something
like that
what's going on yeah something happened
oh yeah I lose my connection was that
chess huh I don't know what that was who
that was really weird I don't know if
that was me or test Kong anyway the
Queen doesn't belong on seat or belong
somewhere on this e to h5 diagonal so
weights of course doing completely fine
here but this probably was not the ideal
way to play it on play a six stop night
b5 maybe you play for c5 g3 I could take
I could play Knight h5 c5 also I think
I'll go for it I'm just gonna play C 5
and I'm basically asked what he's doing
he's got this Bishop on b1 on this long
diagonal where I've bought all these
good ponds so III don't know what he's
trying to do so so yeah okay anyway at
least the time is still good even though
I see I lost a bunch of time that such
is life so ok so it takes I can take
with the pawn or the night both are
possible Knight takes looks right
objectively I'll take with the night I
don't see a good reason not to take of
the night I mean he's got this bishop in
his queen he's two-piece and now b4 was
aggressive but with the slew sponsor on
b4 and c4 it's not so trivial so he
plays Knight e4 I'll take he's gonna
play queenie for rook a 7 protect the
night activate the rook potentially go
to d7
Bishop d6 I cannot play a5 try to try to
weaken this just basically get it so his
loss he is less pawns here on the Queen
side trying reduce and also I all come
up to a file for the rook as well now so
I work eight one if I want it or
Betty maybe I'm just gonna play the
United thing but okay one Bishop C -
yeah I'm I think I'm just gonna play
what am I gonna play Buffy try it
try to exchange bishops the only he's
got the two-on-one here so I feel like
these pawns should be a little bit weak
three okay one takes I'll take with a
knight but my King feels very safe here
- that's that's another look as a queen
d4 Bishop g7 now he's gonna have to move
his queen somewhere off of a d4 position
still is pretty balanced maybe white is
slightly better but it looks quite
reasonable here so he goes Queen h4 I
could 95 takes takes worth d8 and I'm
just in trouble right rook b8 dat came
g7 okay why not let's see actually take
takes rook - yeah I can play Queen d8
and then that interest winning so I
think 95 is a good move
it takes now I'm out of danger whether I
can win on a thought oh wait but if I
play Queen da he can he has Queen d8
still rook b1 work e8
well I can't maybe I take and play King
g7 if I take I mean if we get to the two
versus one in da take 16 g7 rookie 1 or
K 4 okay but it's a safer option and
this is a team match so even if this is
probably objectively a draw I should
should make the bus best moves if I have
the chance big stakes
so he's gonna go rook e1 or okay for
probably c5 I mean c5 should I mean it's
gonna turn into a 4 versus 3 b5 Bishop
d3 doesn't look right so I'm just mapped
it I'm gonna split for verses 3 and try
to truck him because this is technically
a draw
3:54 getting close
I'm just gonna I'm gonna meet tickle I'm
supposed to go rook do you want a gun
okay he finds it so now I'm gonna play
f5 Ivan now I think boys in real trouble
because II for e3 is very very dangerous
and f2 is extremely weak here plays
Bishop c4 so I'm gonna play E for now
got threatening e3 if I need it
C goes G for now is F for the move or
not
F for Bishop d5 f 3 King G 3 Bishop e5
King H or H this is really weird
okay let's see so I get D 3 is always
here F 4 is still here a for F 3 kg 3
okay let's see it
okay cuz I think I'm Chuck meeting him
here if I'm not mistaken
see if I check he's got g5 I play rugby
five pigs okay let's see about four g5
now if I play how do I do this if I tink
he's got that if I play here
okay
yeah now it's just now it's an English
page to Bishop g4 workout for and now he
sees legs long because if he takes I
take and so he's he's just hugs wand
because he he can only move his broken
and he moves the rock I promote and then
he was the rook promote takes takes on
his Bishop can move so he's just
completely lost and now the bishop is
free to move say because I because I
removed the rook from I force so yeah
that was a good win good good win good
way to good way to kind of bounce back
to two straight wins after all I that's
terrible loss
so basically the point is that after I
played this rook before like this whole
concept here with bish before is it if
he doesn't play g5 he plays the very
obvious looking takes e4 then I
play g5 king h5 rookie b6 and it's rook
h6 checkmate
and so here maybe you could play rook e1
and somehow try to survive but it's it's
really hard to believe and then like
when you played the the or when he
didn't play wish before sorry when he
played when he played g5 then worked
before the point is that if he plays
like rook a 1 here then I can just play
well III II to release the same position
but I can even just play like Bishop c7
and now I'm just threatened e3 Chuck
mate because the king is stuck here on
h4 knee is no squares to go to like for
example or okay seven does eateries
Chuck me well he can block with the
bishop with pitch before work e forest
makes a bishop coverage g3 and so
basically was this is really weird like
meeting that box here after work before
I think what he did was close to the the
only try I mean King tree for as
possible as well but I think actually
maybe king g4 is okay before then I have
to move the bishop I'm not sure which
square I goat maybe each to no that's
too extravagant probably just Bishop c7
we're gonna Ricky one maybe maybe why
it's actually okay here if you please
some if he plays King g4 instead of what
he did maybe he's okay but very tricky
very tricky I'm game at any rate so okay
so I think that's what is I is that
tenth that's round 10 right or no is
that right round 11 around 11:00 I guess
there's still four more games to go so
four more to go house Alexis donated 25
bucks good luck
Thank You chouse Alexis for the donation
glad you're enjoying the stream
so okay round twelve starting now let's
see so okay so I'm playing penguin now
so playing penguin so I'm gonna play
something slightly therefore I'm just
gonna see for this is actually I have
this position colors reversed against um
down its vogner and the Isle of Man a
couple weeks ago so I also played this
is white against Mickey Adams and the
first feeding gram free back in uh
everywhere I think it was or March so
pretty familiar with this setup to e6
hassle thank you take maybe three three
school just get the tempo for submission
back Knight c3 before I please Castle
that's interesting I'm gonna go Queen c2
894 takes I think this is all still
standard theory so Queen b6 out it's a
strange move three is now on Bishop c5
minute like night a4
it was Queen a sex interesting I'm just
gonna play a four anyway so now I've got
G for threats also GF like G for f5
there's some tricky threats now so it's
not so simple to play for black and I
also have e5 not to be it's not to be
forgotten so I've got many different
ways of playing here with the pawns
Bishop e7 okay so the obviously played
g4 he plans to sack or maybe not
probably he does he 595 so I'm just
gonna play rook e1 protect the bishop on
III maybe play for e5 maybe not but his
pieces are very badly placed here like
the bish one h5 is terrible his Knights
aren't really active the way he would
like them to be so this looks pretty
good so far
and the the fact that he's using so much
time i think also sells a lot so if I
played g4 here what's he going for you
made me curious I've got to do it I've
got to see what he has here so it takes
with the knight interesting I want to
play h6 try to weaken his Kings side
here B 492 takes take on g7 just Knight
g3 protectee for maybe go to f5 maybe
play e5 basically black has a ton of
problems here on a problem so Queenie
essentially wants to go to like g4 I
guess so I think what is the best way to
place I'm up a lot of time on the clock
so I probably should use them here like
a 594 594 like 94 or something this
looks extremely good I'm gonna play
something simple I'm just gonna play
very technical here with Bishop f3 and
Queen h3 Queen g2 just very solid very
technical because I do have two bishops
as well like if I didn't have the two
bishops would be one thing but with the
two bishops this position is extremely
good for white d3 so now I could play
Knight a5 maybe but why worry why bother
I could take a 7 there are a lot of
possibilities but I'm just gonna go hang
up do I think you have to hold the
for now my rook is free to go to like a
1 C 1 G 1 3 or I think that the knight
now I'm gonna have meeting meeting
threats with Knight a5 coming as well
Thank You 6u5 night of five of them just
gonna go night off five I'm gonna go all
in here try to just chuck made him I
half expect him to resign here but
probably he won't
so c5 played Bishop e5 looks looks
correct if he takes all this take with
the knight on a five and the pawn on g7
and he even though he's got these pawns
here on the Queen side it's very hard to
create anything goes work d3 correctly
good play Knight age 694 I mean I think
q1 is also a little rock c1 this is
about everything as a possibility here
so it's just more matter of not making a
blunder go go row k-16 okay yes I have
rook to one I could take come in all
kinds of possibilities here anything but
Bishop e2 Bishop e2 would be a very very
bad move knight eh six is what I want to
do but I'm just gonna play King he - no
no I'm just gonna take no I'm just gonna
take the take the simple route route to
victory because now my king on e2 he has
no work d2 so he's gonna have to play
work e5 then after 95 I mean even though
he's got it he's got two pawns here my
king if I never lose would be to pond
then the blockers cooked and this is not
gonna get it done either so okay so
that's good so another win that's 12 in
the book so three to go
so okay so this is good so let's see so
I assume we must be doing pretty
decently and I really wish I had that
one back against a pound I mean
considering that I was winning that game
it's really really painful to have lost
that but still there four of us so
hopefully we hopefully that game isn't
going to cost us spot because that that
would be really tragic
so okay so that's so three more to go I
mean any more to go so okay so all right
so let's haul in the books I think right
those around twelve I think I think it
was I'm not sure but at any rate we're
finally getting near the end so
hopefully I mean I I haven't I haven't
heard what the standings are in a little
bit
but we should be we should be close
should be close
should be pretty close
so checking back in on the chat Johnny
nine says we're in second place so
that's that's pretty good
I assume we're behind the Chinese since
I lost that game um but we'll see at any
rate
I guess if it's 15 rounds so 15 times 4
so 60 games so that yeah so we've played
12 rounds so three more to go three more
three more good games
so so yeah so basically I see people in
a chat saying yeah so that one that one
game that I lost is the reason we're not
first but it happens so Allen and
Chester it's glad to know you're using
hangouts ECAR yeah actually I do have
Google I have a gmail open in the
background just getting the updates from
the team manager what the scores are so
so yeah so anyway though we're in the
hunt that's that's a good thing so a
long way to go there's still three
rounds to go three more three more
chances to redeem myself for that
idiotic loss but overall I feel like I
started playing better last like five
six games have been much more in the
rhythm in the first the first like first
three or four were really quite bad it's
only in the last like five or six I've
started getting in the rhythm and clock
Lemaitre rights to two games ago you eat
when you lost you missed a winning move
in the spot were cage six I don't know
what that's referring come a little bit
confused I don't think I ever had a rook
that could go to h6 unless I'm crazy but
anyway so so yeah so so we have what so
three three more to go three more to go
and yes I see some people are saying
that about the flag I've really popped
it up your ear right accents where the
US flag does look weird but anyway
anyway three more to go three more to go
so
well Chesapeake's 51 says you're crazy
if you remember that you never have to
move work age sex well I mean I do
remember my work was never on c6 I think
at all so I never really had a chance to
go to h6 on but but yeah anyway no no
big deal no big deal
okay so round 13 so okay so goo Santos
the guy so so we do your plate against
Magnus and the in the speed blitz
challenge so okay it's time I am gonna
play solid at this point in the match I
feel like it's it's it's paramount also
to not do anything stupid especially on
the wind towards the end better better
not to go insane and try to risk risk go
go for a win or a loss or on this but
okay obvious apparently he wants to draw
so I mean itís just leads to force draw
I think so yeah wow that was exciting
super exciting um yeah there's there's
like no I can play on here not in this
situation so yeah such as life
nice there should be seven you should
buy for mm-hmm now there's there's no
need to be stupid it's a it's a team of
that can I can't throw away can't throw
away anything so yeah
all right you guys I'm I'm gonna run to
the restroom again and I'll be back in a
in a few minutes
[Music]
all right you guys
yeah so what to do what to do what to do
I mean I really would have liked to play
on but I mean the position of slept I
couldn't really do anything now what I
don't know is where they in is were they
in like third place or something or not
that's what I don't know because that's
the only thing reason I could see him
not um it's the only reason I could see
them not him taking the quick draw yeah
ex-convict rights he's not drinking
anything why bathroom breaks off and I
think I've gone to the restroom twice
and in the three hours that this event
has been going so I don't think that's
too bad actually um so anyway so so
that's that was round 13 I believe so
based on my attitude is something like
if there is something like in round 15
for example where I'm black and I
absolutely have to try and win then I
definitely will take much more risks but
but but yeah you know in general in
general it doesn't feel like the right
thing to do so okay so let's but to two
rounds to go hang gadot says it sounds
like you're planning to end the stream
soon I don't like that not necessarily I
think it's just that on my you know I'm
streaming this event right now so so so
you say yeah like I mean I I might I
might keep playing a little after but
it's really hard when you play a super
long event like there's a standard like
eight or nine games that it wouldn't be
such a big big deal excuse me on but
with it being 15 games like the the
stress level gets up there a little bit
more so so yeah and it's like chespin
saying there's a 1.1 point between the
top three teams so so basically I just
have to keep keep playing well and again
that's the thing like you know if
there's only one point between the top
three teams and you know I decided I'm
gonna play on against kou-san off for
example and I lose that game that I'm
then right there I I hurt the team
tremendously so that's that's why it's
kind of important to just just be smart
at this point
so all right so what's coming up around
14 Knox I think so
two more to go to Mork
so I assume this is going to be the big
break so if you guys have any questions
on feel free ask
stay sorry about that you guys looks
like I got logged out for a second there
sorry about that on my back yeah I'll
come back okay good yeah okay so yeah so
yeah I accidentally click the link that
um that just be posted about the
standings or something so anyway dark
fanfare lights how many rating points
your planks trying to decrease due to
live common commentating um I don't know
I think it varies I mean I think like in
this event at least like one of the two
draws early on probably would not have
been a draw if I wasn't streaming um I
think for sure I would not have lost
that game chess panics I would have been
a little bit quicker in terms of moving
as well like you know it's it's not just
commentating but it's also like when you
when you get lower on timings that also
plays a big role as well so I think it's
a bit of everything so two more rounds
to go I mean probably I can tell by just
where chest Panda is rating wise if I
see him but actually I don't see him on
here somehow
hard for me to tell what where where
they all are so Casey's a 28 32 I feel
like he was around there when I played
him so probably he's drawn some games as
well an ally see right
actually I'm he Cara have you ever
visited Ireland I actually answered this
once before or earlier on the on the
feed yeah I mean I did actually I I've
been to Ireland I've been to Dublin so
it's a a little bit that I've seen of
seen of Ireland is great
so okay so - two more games two more
games I'm guessing the games are I don't
know what my game finish action let's
finish at least like six or seven
minutes ago now so II should be winding
down that's that's actually the hardest
thing that we're one of the things that
I dislike the most about these events is
like when you have a quick game you end
up like sitting around for five to ten
minutes so so yeah
okay so still so I mean I can't seem to
see the game so I really wish I could
just see the the games from the
tournament but actually maybe I can
actually know now that I look maybe
actually looks like I can't kind of can
see but there's still some games going
at least
um someone okay right yeah crybaby
monkey says there's a game on drinking
crap kramnik or I played Queen III and
ended up winning why doesn't might try
that more oh my wife doesn't try that
more because it still it still is a draw
cramming chose to try and play on which
is the reason that um
well I do love black for draw but I
think even well even the way that
cramming played probably was okay before
he blundered so that's why people don't
play and so me and three says are you
gonna do live frames and later later
series of the tournament - yeah I mean
I'll consider doing I feel like the only
issue with that is that since they're
slower games first of all someone could
potentially listen in to what I'm saying
and then secondly someone could also
like suggest moves in chat which of
course it would be quite illegal so I'm
not sure if that if I could do it or not
if I if I can then I definitely would I
mean for sure that's that's definitely
my my attitude but again I'm not I'm not
sure since the game they're gonna be
slower
so all right so where are we still some
games going it looks like couple maybe
not Manning
chespin writes trust me 94 rights are
how sad are you about the Yankees um
I'm not that sad I mean I think the
reason that it's it's disappointing it's
because kind of if they had lost in Game
four like they were supposed to to the
Astros that they would not have even
gotten to a game seven but once I won
Game four and then they they have that
great great win in Game five as well you
it was hard not to get swept up by it
all and get really into it and then to
like the inky's go super super quiet
their bats just like kind of died in
Game six and seven um you know it's just
disappointing but anyway I guess okay so
oh wait Mikey Mac's card sorry I
actually wasn't paying attention
sorry you guys I didn't notice that okay
so this is looking similar to the last
games I had again thrown against um
penguin that is yeah probably Bishop d6
or okay he's gonna go Bishop c5 he's
gonna do the other one so it's gonna be
probably very slim
similar to my game against penguin
although here the bishops on a better
Square on c5 minute on d6 Ricky eight
nine inch for Knight e5 okay interesting
594 I think of
a good move
which would be 4 X 1 teenage - might
allow Knight g4 so I just want to avoid
any tricks d5 my Knight c3
movie sucks interesting okay now I can
play a four if I want to I 4g4 all moves
are in play here I have five
three let's see five maybe
case you guys are wondering why I've
gone quiet I've gone a little bit quiet
because the the last round did not go
very well for us I'm not sure if we're
actually um still in the second place or
where we are but we'll see
it takes now I'll take on our six
if I took on c3 I would hang the e4 pawn
so I had to take on f6 I think we should
take seater is a bad move though he has
better p2 and then I don't know if I'm
gonna take on g7 or I'm just gonna take
the bishop and leave one with these
double off pawns but I suspect that he
overlooked fishcakes off six
okay so it plays G off now I can take
pushback three or play Queen C three
both look very interesting I think I'm
just gonna take c3 and here this should
be very very good for white quite a for
coming Black has these terrible double F
pawns and I've got this great night here
on f5 which is just crushing it's
extremely good P so rookie six I'll play
with d1 8 take the deef try to take the
D file now maybe he'll play Knight g6
I'm not I'm not sure what he's trying to
play it for just can't shake it okay so
King in shades I'm just gonna play b3
prophylactic eight double the rooks on
the D file now takes probably he'll take
with the night I would assume you're d1
Ricky five interesting okay turkeys I
don't know if I take he'll take with the
up on I don't have to take I can also
split like we know really which i think
is what I'm gonna do we need six that's
a good move
thanks I think I've worked these seven
here yeah this should just be completely
winning eight and Queens you for
probably and now we're Group G 800 work
out five I'll just play cleanup and yeah
I'm just up in exchange here black
spawns are terrible so I would expect
him to resign I guess he's not going to
UM to say if I go King f1 or FB to s for
this this looks good
ah he's Knight f3 trying to force on
something extinct u6 g4g for 1982
I'm glad checkmate here with rook to 7
and then work h7 cell yep okay so it's
another win so one more to go one more
so okay so it's around 14 so what one
more game to go so let's keep it rolling
keep it rolling
so so what so one more one one more game
and hopefully hopefully we qualify so
kitty kitty hiss hiss rights eric is
hoping you are tired when you get to him
is Eric even online I don't actually see
Eric online it's the online I I don't
actually see him online yeah I just I
don't see Eric online right now so
that's a rights he's in this chat yeah I
mean he's he's hiding in the chat
I'm not surprising
so what exactly I'm since I see a bunch
of people are mentioned this Eric match
against Magnus was I mean I know they
play it I didn't actually see any of the
games I mean I've heard about it but I
didn't didn't see anything so who knows
so okay so it's wrong 14 so I mean we
should be somewhere we have to be doing
reasonably well should be somewhere
somewhere near the top maybe their order
I mean yeah I guess the real question is
how far ahead if we are we have fourth
place that's really the only question so
so Eric Eric went five games so Magnus
beat him 29 to 5 so that's like so what
is that that's five times so that's like
that's six to one it's like six to one
yeah six to one though actually six to
one is not um yeah four actually six to
one probably is about that's probably
about what I'm gonna score two I think I
think six to one is about right but in
terms of rating I think the thing is
isn't Magnus is rating inactive so
probably if he if you plays he probably
gains a lot of points so that that's
probably the other thing so I'm not sure
but that's does what I think at least so
all right so if we're are we really
three and a half ahead of fourth that's
that's the big question so if people are
saying that but I'm not not sure
so let's let's see
there's my alert
it's the last round you guys okay some
simple the best I what I don't know is
how far I had a fourth we are so that
makes it tricky but I'm gonna trust you
guys in the chat saying that were three
and a half so I'm gonna play solve this
game since you said over three and a
half ahead so somehow we're not three
and a half ahead you guys I'm gonna hold
you I'm gonna hold everyone your rectly
responsible
so pretty pretty dry opening so far so
we need to Queenie seven Queenie six was
also playable doesn't doesn't really
matter that much
very very equal position again I trust
you guys in the chat saying we're three
and a half I've had a fourth fourth
place so if we aren't then I'm gonna
have someone to get angry at later but
I'm gonna trust that you guys know what
you're talking about
there's I'll take I'm gonna counsel now
king cakes probably was a bad move
because now I think he's gonna get into
trouble so he goes can you to Bishop c5
I'm gonna get Ricky Ricky g8 it was king
c3 this looks maybe why it's okay maybe
I thought I have my doubts somehow maybe
why it is okay yeah unfortunately why
maybe is okay here despite his king
being like terribly plays I'm gonna try
to try to make it messy now try to
create something here even though
they're really probably is nothing we'll
see what he wants to do this b5 is p3
probably takes King b3 okay so please
rookie one but now I think I can play
work d8 because now if he takes I take
and then I'm gonna get rook d2 and if he
doesn't I'm threatening to take and go
rook to you two anyway
or takes rook c5 work t2 same same thing
basically
so rookie - okay but now I can take and
play rook c5 track now I'm gonna go rip
d2 assuming he goes king bee 3 I'd be
very very very embarrassing to play
automatically play rook teach who he
goes King he slips King before you
automatically go rookie - and just lose
the game I'd be very embarrassing so he
has rook e1 new then I can take take I
can take the Seabrooke check into some
check King these six and I think I'm
that I'm probably just winning
so just see 400 cases before obviously
tink
Bob and then takes rookie ones who's
gonna be tricky here or I can play B 5 B
5 also looks interesting I think they
like b5 more actually
[Music]
okay so what else can he do you can play
rook c1 but then I'll take on c4
probably with the rook it takes I just
play rook b5 and then repeat to please
King c3 I go with G 2 rooks e3 doesn't
make sense since his works already on
this open e file so I'm not sure what
he's gonna do here so he goes rook e1
okay so now Brooke you want I could play
rook c4 I could also play B takes now B
takes a little stupid over g2 or key 8
is just nothing so I think I will go
rotate c4 is now I'm also threatening a
rook d3 made at some point too it's also
important to note that if my King gets
out to like b6 it's gonna be very safe
here now why does these two Brooks but
the King protected by these three pawns
is extremely safe now I'm threatening
work d3 checkmate as walls between c5
play 5 I could have played f6 to maybe
have 6 was better it worked he had the
amazing work takes B fives are yeah I
should have played f6 instead of a 5
probably but anyway no I said now he's
threatening work d8 shot so have to be
precise play rook CC 2 is there
checkmate
there is no checkmate but it still looks
like the best move
alright so now this is just losing cuz
now wait to rock his passive having to
defend from that side of my rooks active
it it's basically hitting hitting all
his pawns and all the wrong wrong spots
h6 take the rook back now I'm just gonna
play a four so I lock these pawns now
and now this is a permanent
naso b3 I could take I can play rookie
to also um okay to actually looks like
the correct move cuz King before okay
Ricky for now I can go King
I'll go King off six is now g2 is
hanging also before work would be to now
I can just exchange and it's Toulouse
and King upon on game after c5 cuz no I
can't can just come right in or takes
and King b5 I can also just go king d4
to so king b5 King D for so okay so
that's a good way to finish um yeah I
mean I I I mean really what did I score
12 out of 15 so I said I want to score
13 so basically yeah like if I win that
one game against chest panda instead of
losing that you know um I would have
gone the score that I was base leaks you
hoping for so not terrible overall
hopefully hopefully we qualified I mean
I guess that's the main thing so I mean
I'm just gonna keep the stream going at
least at least until at least until I
know for sure that we've called
qualified
so let's yeah I mean I guess let's let's
just all hey I'll hang out here see
what's happening um see if see if we
qualified or not that's really the I
mean though the only question so so I I
was told that we're on two points ahead
going into the final round not three and
a half so okay so anyway yeah I'm also
saying so it says we're at thirty three
and a half the pandas were thirty five
so again that one game basically flips
it but I've got one loss of that game
against a Yankee that I should have one
basically flips everything but as long
as we qualify it's not not a big deal
really
but if we don't qualify I'm going to be
pretty pretty annoyed let me put it that
way so okay so
so I don't know I mean I guess there's
still some games going not sure I mean
what's what's going on I mean I'll just
hang out here in the chow to you guys
until I hear back on gchat in regards to
what's going on um but uh but yeah I
mean play pretty well today pretty well
at the end the last like last like six
78 games I mean once I really found the
rhythm I played quite well I mean okay I
lost the game that I should have won
against yang Yi but but otherwise I mean
I really found the rhythm the first
games were not good but but everything
else is good um
tan writes how did you lose to Tarlov I
didn't lose that game I won that in game
against our left the only game I lost
was to a yang Yi chest chest panda so um
so yeah so it's pretty good pretty
pretty good overall could have been
better it could have been much worse
so we'll see um
so darn darn darn fanfare says currently
you're a three and a half ahead of
fourth place so that basically means
fourth has to win on fourth has to win
her fourth place has to win all their
games so I assumed that most like that
has not happened but but yeah I mean
we'll see we'll see him yeah I mean
there was double edge at the end but
basically if I had played the right or
if I played rook t1 shocked or what
works see one check sorry when he had to
go kini to instead of sort of one move
later I think I think was probably
winning for me so it's it's
disappointing obviously but yeah if we
qualify that's really all that matters I
mean I don't mind anything else really
if we qualify but but we'll see we'll
see
so still waiting to hear on what's what
the what the deal is with qualified or
not alright well we'll see we'll see I
assume
pretty soon but assuming we qualify then
yeah I'll definitely be playing for the
Seattle team and at least a few games
probably the minimum because I think the
matches are going to be the matches are
going to be probably during the next
like two months mainly so it's gonna be
very hard obviously playing in the Grand
Prix in London I mean during the Grand
Prix maybe I'll play anyway since
objectively in the Grand Prix there's I
I don't have a chance to qualify so what
we'll see but but they're still on
hopefully there's a lot more shots left
for me this year in the Pro Trust League
so darn fanfare says now you are only
three points ahead so three points ahead
would mean that someone of the 4-1 I
assume one of the four wanted me we we
lost a game but if they if they can if
they can win if they can win all for
them then good for that I mean I think
realistically is pretty unlikely oh
nevermind actually Greg Greg hotty where
it's max don't begin till January 17th
so ok so I actually was completely
unaware of that move by move right so
you're out of candidates for sure I mean
I won't say that I am for sure I mean
nothing is nothing is certain but I
think most likely I won't be in it
that's that's what I would say Gorter
manly rights what is your opinion on the
economic deficiencies seen in the rural
Chesapeake Bay colonies of the late 17th
century
um I don't understand the questions a
question like we're talking like about
like the like the southern states like
Virginia and West Virginia or I'm
slightly confused um but anyway I think
the bottom line is there are there are a
lot of issues in the world today and I
think the economic inequality is growing
so I think there are a lot of a lot of
issues again I I can answer these
questions much more in depth but I'll
save them for on for for another time a
little bit tired and getting into some
long discussion you know economics or or
even finance right now it's not probably
not the best idea
so um okay so let's see so I got that
message okay got one and a half and that
round should be enough to get in so wait
that means we only scored one and a half
out of four so Wow
why don't half out of four but I guess
we're in second so I guess that means
that on both teams both to both Seattle
and the third team we both had pretty
bad in the last round so so so yeah
anyway it looks like we qualified those
so yeah so that's that's good so I guess
I guess we qualified so I'll be playing
in on then I'll be playing in a January
so it's good god we've got got the job
done I mean of course personally I
really wanted that one extra one that I
should have had but again it's it's team
thing and really just just qualifying
it's really the only goal because I mean
it's not like you know in a sea we're
already in and you play a bad game you
lose a match I mean you're gonna have
more chances but here if you don't
qualify um y'all can have another chance
so so yeah all right you guys um so I
think on that note that I'm gonna end
the stream for now so I will be back I
don't know when I'll be back then I'm
like I'll probably be on tomorrow since
I'm not I haven't watched much football
this year and tomorrow is Sunday so and
the Titans don't play tomorrow so I
think probably I'll be on tomorrow so
most likely I'll be streaming tomorrow
so until then you guys have a good
evening
or a good morning wherever in the world
you are and until next time good night
everybody